let's just get as many trumps in federal
office and as possible let's just you
know how old is is Baron can he run for
Congress yeah he's gota be 25 he's not
Old Baron Trump he hasn't graduated high
school yet I mean he's he's got a minute
I think I'll make an exception to put
more trumps in in in government just get
them all in there because it pisses off
runs for class president then he he's 17
we're going to get accused of uh
promoting oligarchy on the show right
care royal family because it pisses off
the machine and then we'll we'll figure
out it's it's like The Simpsons when you
know when they had the the the what do
they have the lizard problem and so they
were like they'll get dogs and then how
do you do with the dogs and then they're
like we'll get you know they increase
keep get the animals bigger and bigger
until they're finally like we'll have
gorillas Go and Kill the animal and then
they're like but then they have a
gorilla problem and skinners I think it
was Skinner is like no that's the best
part when winter comes they simply
freeze to death so it's just like we'll
get get all the trumps in there let them
just just trump it out trump it out man
and then you know we'll figure it out
later I thought you made a good point
that ramas Swami is not the perfect
candidate because I think a lot of
people might right now be looking for
Perfection and if they don't see it
they're going to turn away and vote for
what they think is safe but you're never
going to find perfection you've got to
go with you got to take risks and to to
to counter that though if you look at
some of the folks that are anti that are
in like Maga you know in the Maga
mindset right
they're they're attacking the because
they believe he's too perfect they think
he's OB Obama 2.0 I mean there's a lot
of different theories on that but at the
end of the day like it's it's Deeds not
words right and if you look at what V
has done for his personal life for his
family you know for the state he lives
in his community I mean you don't have
any VI ramaswami employees jumping out
saying this guy's a terrible leader VI
effectively said he wants to cut funding
to Israel not not as blunt he says he
wants to get them sustainable to the
point through US support to where we
don't need to be supporting them anymore
which is the intelligent way of saying
like hey we should not be that's bold
because you know Nikki Haley is like she
loses her mind my objection to Ronald
swy to be honest is you know again I'm
very lucky to be in position who haven't
got to ask him this but he has he has a
more flexible view on hb1 H1B visas than
I do I I feel like I would prefer
someone to take a stronger stance on
border and border security and and
reducing even legal immigra legal
immigration into the country as well as
illegal immigration but that is not to
say that he couldn't do amazing things I
am not convinced this is the cycle I
don't think he would like being VP to
Trump but he has incredible potential
and I think it's better to have a a a
deep bench of people who can do good
things for the country even like we
always talk about it like it's just the
presidency in the VP but it's really not
there are tons of cabinet positions
there are lots of things that we could
have talented intellectual and
accomplish people uh step into and
really benefit the American public I get
the uh the Obama criticism they they
they feel like VI is Obama 2.0 I've
thought that a couple times I've even
said it on the show VI the snake I
called him a couple times and it's like
I feel that like he's an order he's
willing to bend with the wind like a
read even to the point maybe where he'll
snap like Obama did and then the big
business takes over but that's why I
like seeing him in a VP position because
he'll watch it happen all around him and
he won't have to be the one getting
co-opted and he'll see how Don like kind
of came out on SK I mean he communicated
to us he didn't want to be someone
watching he wants to be at the head of
the organization
andbe if he with theal maybe should run
for Govern of Ohio maybe should into a
leadership Ro on a smaller scale and
then you know he's so young he has so
much potential to do a lot of things if
he doesn't run this cycle I'm sure he'll
run again who do the Democrats have in
terms of Youth
AOC and like Max Frost that's like the
guy they always talking about he's like
the youngest gav new yeah but Max Frost
you said yeah I that's I think that's
his name Florida he's not the same level
of AOC
not yet VI like stepped onto the stage
and hit it out of the ballpark and and
Skyrocket in terms of uh just like
notoriety notability you know the things
he was saying the conversations was
having the way he was having them
inspired a lot of people very very
quickly and resulted in this viral like
notability yeah the guys loved in Ohio
like I said man I met him before he even
had political aspirations he was just
coming around talking about I mean he
was he was a Libertarian you know he
said it some some people are arguing
have made the claim that he wants to be
a senator out of Ohio I think he's
denied that yeah I mean there's been
people advocating for it you know
because of the senate race in Ohio right
now is is highly contested so you know I
think V standing out the way he has
during his presidential run has drawn a
lot a lot more attention to him when uh
when Gavin Newsome went over to China I
got the vibe like oh they're running
Gavin Newsome that's what's gonna happen
so I I now I
still that should I I I just I can't
identify with Democrats at all because
if I were like this guy wants to be the
president so he went to China and that's
how I know he wants to be the president
like no no no tore the US leave
California and come see you know
industrial towns in the midwest that
were devastated by manufacturing leaving
go to West Virginia and talk to people
who are affected by the opioid crisis
like if you want to be president of the
United States shouldn't you talk to
Americans why would you be like I will
go overseas this is a great idea I just
I can't relate to It Go spank little
boys while I'm playing basketball I've
never seen a governor go speak with the
president of China before have you I've
never seen that before so weird huh yeah
that was highly uh unique
unorthodox novel you know the great
nation of California needs
representation in China I don't see
Biden being the nominee I don't see him
being the candidate for the Democrats
yeah because look at the polls right now
Jen yuger said he's only running
basically to bring awareness to that the
fact that Biden's goingon to lose and
that he's like what I have to run
because people don't understand Biden
will lose he bought the domain Biden is
going to lose.com oh that's hilarious
like and he said Republicans should want
Biden in the race and I'm like I agree
well and then and then um Dean Phillips
out of Minnesota launched his campaign
to challenge Biden after pretending he
wasn't going to for a minute yeah he's
to the Tweet we pulled up it's it's kind
of interesting that we're we have a an
open Democrat who's like I'm I'm I think
I could maybe run a race uh I I had
thought when RFK decided to run as an
independent perhaps there was pressure
from the DNC being like you have to get
out of here we can't have anyone else
but obviously that message hasn't hasn't
trickled down to the rest of the rank
and file if we have someone out of
Minnesota saying well I might throw my
hat in the ring after we've already have
an independent candidate challenging
essentially Biden I know they pretend
like it's both Trump trump and Biden
it's really not I mean no one wants
Biden to run this is what's happening I
was uh I did I wasn't here when chank
was on the show uh because I was in
Miami but I was thinking about
progressivism that's a term that gets
thrown I'm Progressive think about
progressivism and I'd love to talk to CH
to talk to you about this directly too
chank progress means to move forward so
you can progress towards a cliff and
then walk off the cliff where are you
progressing that's a big part of being
Progressive what are you progressing to
and also how are you progressing are you
progressing as a wild mob disorganized
or are you progressing in an organized
fashion they're they're they're watch
marching towards the cliff and we need
to we need to that needs to be discussed
debated and observed because that's a
big part of you can't just say you're
Progressive and it you don't want to be
regressive but unless well it depends if
you're about to walk off a cliff you do
want to be regressive or maybe you want
turn left what's the what's
transgressive
transgressive yes we the transgressive
is is that the right words transgressive
we don't want to go forward the forward
is the cliff we don't want to go
backwards that's too far but we want to
go kind of back and to the left you know
we should go back a little bit because
the left has gone nuts but we mostly
just want to turn left maybe degressive
or turn right I want to go back into the
right I was going to say I will only
join this movement the transgressive
movement if we're going back into the
right transgressive I I'm into the
transgressive move M then but backing to
the left sounds equally as bad because
ultimately it'll be like why are we
going back we should go forward again
and it'll just heso back to where it was
going we do have the 20s in the chat for
what Ian had said because it is correct
the the left seems to be Progressive for
the sake of progress but progress for
the sake of progress is blind they're
just saying just keep doing it keep
doing it why not why not and you're like
eventually you're like hey there's a
naked man dancing in front of children
and they're like progress and you're
like okay but this is not what we
thought we were progressing to
transgress we want Star Trek and like
you know replicators and cold and
graphine not naked men dancing for
children okay that's not progress that's
something weird actually I think that's
transgressive Amen brother amen sister
that's what I meant no I think I think
progress in the in the relative sense
like what would Americans view as
progress it would
be space travel uh you know uh um
colonizing other planets when you ask
someone what do you think the future
looks like these are the things they
they they Envision they Envision oh
people aren't hungry anymore people
aren't starving food replicators
spaceships that's what they think of
when they think of us advancing and
progressing what's happened is the left
has hijacked progress and now they've
got naked dudes dancing in front of
children and I'm like okay that's that's
like veering off the course yeah so so
we're driving here's a better way to put
it we're driving on this road and you've
got a rocky Cliffs side to your right
and a sheer Cliffs side straight drop to
your left and they' they've turned the
car to the left and we're like guys if
we keep keep this angle up we're going
off the edge we got to correct it and go
back to the the the dreams of of what we
used to focus on for a moment let us
Congress meaning move together and turn
around and then we'll go to space but
now so we Define where we're going very
clearly paint the picture chank and
everyone that wants to be Progressive or
consider himself paint the picture of
where you want to end up I like this
word Gress yes for currently we should
egress yes we should we're about to
egress the super chats but also after
you explain where we're going and you
you outline it in such a vivid way that
people can picture it then explain how
we're going to get there piece by piece
and you'll have a lot of people
following
you yeah see the left is mostly just we
should just do what we do for whatever
reason which is the military war machine
from 1913 Federal Reserve banking yeah
it's the Never Enough party right they
say you know we've accomplished this
Progressive goal but now we have to it
and we there there's no there's no
reason why it's just continuing to push
boundaries forward and forward and I
think that allows people with really
nefarious agendas to step in and say I'm
benefiting from this kind of dis this
this dissolve into
chaos Anarchy you know disguises as
progressivism in in so many different
ways I mean true progressivism like like
you're explaining I mean is realistic it
has reasonable goals and you you know
where you're going with them I mean it's
just total Destruction that's what
transgressive means actually means just
viol the social norms or regular Norms
we're doing so really in reality they
are transgressive because that's the
definition of the word they're not
progressing towards anything that's
meaningful and the goalposts are always
moving too post every day transgressor
like swerving the wheel left and right
as you're going stop it uh oh Serge has
got the details yeah it's like it has to
do with like breaking social boundaries
or moral boundaries yeah so
transgressive would be to like end like
revolting against moral and social
boundaries which was literally what the
progressive today is saying that they're
doing so thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net